alright let's look at some of the
interesting posts on the david pakman
show subreddit the david pakman show
subreddit is of course one of the
largest independent progressive media
subreddits out there we now have more
than 17,000
of our viewers and listeners subscribed
at david pakman.com slash reddit someone
is not pleased with my predictions user
r execute says I love David and his
well-thought-out opinions but I hate how
much he says things are happening
exactly how I predicted them in reality
he just says what the public consensus
is in these matters are such as Trump
getting acquitted and then since says
things are happening just as he
predicted as if he's behind the scenes
crunching all the numbers it's pretty
disingenuous from a guy who I think is a
truly honest player in the political
talk game I don't know what do you think
listen if this is concern trolling then
very well done if it's not sometimes the
outcome is pretty obvious and I still
tell you when I think that's the case if
the outcome is obvious why would I come
up with a different prediction if it's
likely to be wrong merely to be unique
and this actually relates to something
I'm going to talk about on tomorrow's
show we have a real problem in the sort
of media space I guess I would call it
with what I call hot take culture where
unless you come up with something
completely one-sided black and white and
it has to be something no one else is
saying it's considered either
disingenuous or not interesting or
whatever the case may be I tell you
things as they are we have a continuing
conversation on this program and when I
say just like I've been telling you what
I mean is I and the audience have been
engaged in a conversation for a while
and when I say this is going down
exactly the way we've been talking about
for months what I'm referencing is the
fact that you and I have been in this
discussion for a long time and things
are happening as we've observed and
predicted them to go so listen if if
this is your biggest gripe with me I'm
probably doing okay I think if it's just
concerned trolling very very well done
oh there was last week I mentioned that
I was again
sort of categorized as gay on my
Wikipedia page which doesn't bother me
in any way it's factually untrue there
would be nothing wrong if if I were gay
I just happened not to be and during an
edit war that started on my Wikipedia
page a user named oh babe 69 was able to
take a screenshot of when someone edited
the personal life section of my wiki
page to say Pakman resides in Boston he
is in a long-distance relationship with
Kyle kolinsky host of secular talk who
lives in New York he also stole sam
cedars intellectual property so very
very clever and that edit did not stick
on my Wikipedia page and in fact this is
just to kind of put a final point on the
Wikipedia thing because of the amount of
vandalism on my page at one point
someone renamed me David gay Pakman like
gay was my middle name it was a complete
edit war the page has now been protected
where I think only certain users are
allowed to edit it or something like
that it's amazing what people have time
in their lives for lastly from the david
pakman show subreddit user password goes
here says quote booed at judge is david
the only one who can pronounce Budaj
edge you know what's hilarious about
this I am being both praised and
destroyed for my pronunciation of Pete
Budaj edge the reason I say Pete Budaj
edge it's a slight exaggeration but at
the very beginning of Pete's candidacy
when nobody knew how to pronounce his
last name he said it's like the word
boots followed by the word edge twice
boot edge edge and of course when you
say it in conversation you might say
Budaj edge but I am pronouncing it
correctly although maybe a little bit
haltingly and I hear all sorts of
mispronunciations in corporate media yet
somehow people are going after me I'm
not really that angry about it I'm kind
of half kidding join the discussion on
the subreddit at david pakman.com slash
our EDD i-team more than 17,000
subscribers to the subreddit one of us
an employee of reddit that I know about
six months ago actually reached out and
said we love what you're doing with your
subreddit it's amazing
the amount of engagement and people
you've got over there and it is a great
place for political discussion